the Las Vegas Grand Prix last raced here
back in the 80s now tickets for its
long-awaited return went on pre-sale
just this week but as Ryan mathie shows
us longtime fans say they're being
priced out
even the biggest of F1 fans say they
cannot afford to go to next year's race
so many are hoping to capture a view
from a nearby hotel but with
skyrocketing rates fans are having to
compensate I don't even want to think
about it right now because I could cry
if I'm honest Luisa Coates called
Southwest England home where she met her
fiance Duncan when they were just 14.
she's since been diagnosed with breast
cancer and when discussing where the two
would tie the knot what do we do it in
Vegas
at the same time as the Grand Prix
combining the two loves of her life
Duncan and formula one the Grand Prix
returns here a year from now but to
stand track side it'll cost her
thousands when you stop talking and
planning your day planning your big day
it's really
tough to get that image out of your head
thinking that this might might not
happen I jokingly said I should just run
out the house and we can all go on
vacation even locals like Sierra height
says tickets costing up to ten thousand
dollars each are unaffordable especially
for her family of eight flying in for it
add that to an average rate increase of
300 for nearby hotels race weekend
they're taking their money elsewhere
just I mean disappointing I didn't get
tickets but maybe I can run out my house
and it'll be a good trade-off now
important to note this is all still
pre-sale priority interest goes on sale
Thursday with public on sale this
Saturday reporting near Koval and Harmon
Ryan mathie 8 News Now